it is time to see what's trending and
who else would know about what's
trending besides the most trending
person in las vegas las vegas now host
mercedes martinez yeah she's joining us
live from the mix 94.1 studios this
morning mercedes how are you
i'm glad i don't know about that john i
don't think you're right but
let's get to it this morning first up
it's jessica simpson she is back in
charge of her billion dollar business
yes that's right i said billion the
parent company of the jessica symphony
simpson collection
fashion line is filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy protection in august and she
and her mother tina they owned a
minority stake but now they regain total
ownership of the fashion label next up
though let's talk about some bad news
for marvel fans like sherry sherry i'm
so sorry some of its movies have been
delayed this includes
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
that was supposed to actually come out
at the end of march but it now hits
theaters in may thor love and thunder
that was pushed from may to july and
black panther wakanda forever that's
going to hit theaters just before
thanksgiving instead of next summer
john heather i'm sorry i don't mind the
delay i don't mind the delay mercedes
because it gives me more time to catch
up on some of the slash all of the
marvel movies yeah he's going to spend
all weekend at home watching these i
have to catch up
a little bit
mercedes we're hearing you know taking
time to slow things down as as being
celebrated now yeah there's a hashtag
trending let's talk about it
yeah this is really interesting guys
it's the hashtag the art of slow living
so it means you do more
self-care things whether that means
saying no to things or just pampering
yourself
fancy life is better when you can
actually appreciate things as they
happen rather than medically ticking
things off of your to to your to-do list
so i think we should all kind of take a
little break
good
yeah mercedes we'll get you'll get to
the rest of your morning show whenever
we'll finish ours you know whatever it's
all good i need a couch i like this idea
mercedes on the couch
that's you know what that is so
important though honestly i think a lot
of people realize that during the
pandemic you got to live each moment to
the fullest i'm too relaxed to answer
that question
don't relax too much john you got work
to do we depend on you guys i'm done
thanks mercedes
thanks mercedes bye just chill out man
it's gonna be good dude it's all right